[Music]
please welcome the director of plan b
natalie morales
i'm i'm d masking but you can keep yours
on it i think i'm going to feel better
just because you know who wants to get
covered right now
i do i want it so bad clearly
i just i just want to lose some weight
i'm desperate
um
so
you have two films out this year yeah
in the in the middle of the covid times
how did that happen like which one did
you start working on first like when in
the coved timeline did um
did you was this all in the can before
the cobot lockdown happened they were
they were very
simultaneous which was not on purpose um
so i've been working on this movie do i
sound like darth vader right behind this
master is it okay
okay great it's pretty awesome awesome
um so i i've been working on this movie
since uh
i think about 2018 and then we were
slated to start shooting march of 2020
and so i was in syracuse which is where
we shot that
in february prepping
people's hair had been bleached sets had
been built
houses were painted and the friday
before the monday when we were gonna
start shooting we got shut down like the
rest of the world did
um and then i didn't know if it was
gonna come back at all or what was gonna
happen then i was i was just kind of
sitting at home in may i was writing i
was doing whatever i could like whatever
we all could at that time and and uh and
then mark duplass called me and was like
do you speak spanish
i i have a kind of like a seed of an
idea so then
we wrote and we shot language lessons uh
within a month like in four weeks and
then
while i was editing language lessons is
that feedback from me how's that
okay
while we were editing language lessons
uh
i was shooting this
this came back in september and uh we
were i was i was actually doing reshoots
for language lessons on the weekends
while shooting this
and then language lessons came out in
like berlin and south by southwest first
but then this came out on in hulu first
so and then now language lessons comes
out this friday so it's very like
weirdly simultaneous not on purpose
that's amazing i don't recommend it to
doing that many uh that's worked all at
once but it just happened that way and i
couldn't you know drop the ball in
either of them so it sounds exhausting
but it was
now you're probably glad it turned out
that way because i'm very glad you look
like a rockstar stud thank you yeah and
i'm also like very hard to pigeonhole
now you know it's a very different movie
so that's exciting for me
yeah let's let's talk about this so
um
how did this script come to you and and
what made you decide you wanted to do
kind of a
screw ball high school sex comedy right
now puberty is telling you to step on
the gas if your vagina was a car what
would it be a ferrari stays covered up
and completely untouched in the garage
it's a big night for you inviting your
crush
partying
and drinking i feel so stimulated is
this what white privilege feels like
okay good choices
oh [ __ ]
we need the morning after pill i got one
more right here that could be anything
oh girl that's a pill
it's like a really small chance it might
be pcp
well i had not directed a feature
before this now i've done two
um i had not directed a feature before
this and
i wanted to and i didn't i had written
my own and i'd and
that's very hard to do as we all know
when no one will let you do it but i had
directed some episodes of room 104
that's that's the most
i would say the biggest thing that i've
done i've done a lot of music videos all
my friends music videos anybody that
would let me do their music video i did
i did a bunch of funny or die stuff i
did a bunch of sketch stuff
and then um and then mark duplass
actually gave me uh the opportunity to
do room 104 which is what got me into
the dga which is what sort of propelled
me into this space where i was being
kind of considered
for other things
and then and then so this script came to
me
he just asked you out of the blue like
hey would you ever want to direct one of
our episodes of our show he had seen a
music video that i directed for
andrew byrd and really liked it and so
asked me to direct an episode that he
had written and then liked that episode
so asked me to direct another one
um but then so this script the plan b
scripts uh came to me it was already in
the hands of the producers who um
were the or john
hurwitz and hayden schlossberg who had
done harold and kumar and
blockers and
now do cobra kai and have done a bunch
of stuff and i was like there's no way
i'm going to get this
i really liked
the
subversion
of the genre like i really liked i was
like i think
if i did this not to toot my own horn
but if i did this it could be really
special because i feel like there's a
way
that we can give like
the teenage crazy quest like insane
r-rated comedy movie
this
kind of multiple subversions because
you know by the time when i got that
script book smart had not come out so
there was really no
female comedies in this genre at all
not to mention they're not caucasian
and they're not rich and they don't live
in california or lay and they don't go
to fancy parties
and the teenage quest movie that we're
all used to that we've all seen that i
loved that i grew up with was always
like
let's go to the cool party or let's get
the hot girl or let's get you know let's
get alcohol or let's get my dad's car
back in time you know what were you what
were the teen comedies of your era
um i mean
it was like uh
can't hardly wait and uh um 10 things i
hate about you and american pie and i
mean there's also you know the movies
that came before that in the 80s that i
also watched a lot but my i grew up in
the 90s so that's those are the movies
that i watched in the late 2000s
um
i think you know what i'm going to do
i'm going to step further away from you
and i am going to take off my mask
because i cannot okay
hi you could just say that you really
dislike me no i just really don't know
about honesty here at film independence
i don't want to get coveted so this
feels like six feet right
okay here we are
i'll try to breathe in this god i could
not breathe all right did you where you
guys hear me going
every two seconds
anyway now i'm gonna talk a lot cooler
um so
the
uh so
so not only did it subvert that like
female and and you know non-white thing
but also the quest in this movie is
basic healthcare which had not been
really done in the in the way that like
it was this crazy r-rated comedy and i
was like i want to go all the way with
that like
i want to show a dick i really want to
do it i want to go nuts with it i i
think that girls deserve that we've
gotten so many
insane gross out like
r-rated crazy movies uh that star
teenage boys and we've never had that
with girls and we're just as
horny and weird as any other teenage boy
so why
shouldn't we have that and why not do it
and why not go all the way and and and
you know the fact
that having a movie like that may
attract people to watch it that need the
messages that are underneath that um is
exciting to me and the sort of like
medicine with your sugar is exciting to
me my hope is that you're along for this
ride and you get to know these girls and
you're laughing your ass off and then
they get to the planned parenthood and
you're like oh wow oh this is what this
movie's about [ __ ] they should not be on
this road trip at all they should not be
here at all
um they shouldn't have to go through
this and neither should anybody in this
country um so that that was what
attracted me to it long answer so
where i mean let me talk whose show is
this sorry uh
where's the two in so in the script were
the two women already pocs was that yes
um yeah no that that was the that was
the original um that was the original
goal yeah so talk about your casting
process these two are amazing aren't
they and i don't think that i have seen
them in any i looked them both up and i
think one's a broadway star right well
she's done the same off-broadway stuff
you could tell she's she's saying um
uh
the song at the end the man i feel like
a woman that's singing that's her yeah
oh my god that's really good um i was
like i want to end the movie with the
song and i want kuhu to cover it mostly
because we can't afford shania twain but
also because i wanted to cover it and
victoria's career started on the disney
channel right yeah she did she did some
disney channel stuff and she was on teen
wolf the newer one um
and how did you know that they could
pull this off this stuff
here i'll tell you this um victoria was
uh a recast she was because our our
original um
lupe was not lupe it was ling ling she
was a chinese-american girl and she was
not able to do it the when the movie
came back in september she was on a job
and she was not able to do it so we went
on a on a big search in the two weeks we
had before we started filming and i was
very scared because i was like if their
relationship doesn't work and if these
actors aren't good and if they don't
have good chemistry the movie falls
apart like you don't care about these
people and it doesn't that is what it is
about it it's their friendship
and so we had already exhausted
really even though we continued to open
it we had already exhausted like
literally every asian american actress
in that age range when we had cast the
person we had cast previously
and
and so we decided to open it up a little
bit to other ethnicities um just to see
what we could get and victoria
um
came in and just blew us away and they
had to do their chemistry read on zoom
they had never met and they had to
pretend they were best friends
on zoom and they made us cry and we were
like oh okay this is special they have
it and and
man like they really that's that's what
i was looking for was that chemistry and
they really pulled it off it would have
been a very bad movie had they not had
that even even if they were both great
actors had they not had that real
friendship feeling it wouldn't have
worked yeah
i mean i'm one of those people as a
former actor who believes that comedy
what's done in here is way harder than
drama it's hard to make people laugh
and
um talk about like
directing this like crazy physical
comedy was it
because you've done that somewhat in
your career
yeah i mean i i'm a huge huge buster
keaton fan like huge it's maybe the
biggest inspiration
for my work and and and what i do and
like
and but even before i discovered buster
keaton that's what i did i did a lot of
physical comedy in my sketch comedy it's
always what i enjoyed doing i also
started out
my acting career really on this show
called the middleman where i did a lot
of stunts and i did my own stunts and
i've done stunts throughout and so i
really like that i've always liked
action stuff and i've always liked
action comedy a lot
um
and
i think that you know you're right i
think comedy is difficult but it's not
as like
the reason they both blend together in
this movie for me is because it's all
about honesty like you just have to you
just have to be as honest as possible to
the moment and if you create ridiculous
situations for people to be in
their honest reactions are going to be
funny you know and i just happen to have
really great actors um and also really
great improvisers like um edie patterson
who played doris in the gas station like
that
that that
that
i had to rewind that and watch it a few
times oh that was at um
that was at like 5 a.m after having been
there all night it was completely
improvised by her and the second that
she said
uh he
ripped down the seam of his balls i was
like that's going in the movie
that's definitely going in the movie
there's no way that's not going in the
movie my my um
my assistant on the movie the director's
assistant came up to me was like i have
to go home i have pee in my pants it's
like okay
i totally understand we were dying we
were laughing so hard and moses storm
who plays andy the drug dealer also that
was like a whole week of night shoots
which are hard and it was raining and it
was freezing
and he was just it was just so funny um
so thank god for all the casts i mean
they're all they're all fantastic
so
let's talk about this full frontal junk
yeah that's my favorite subject
there's so much full frontal junk in
shows
it's so funny that you ended up making
something that has so much full frontal
junk because it feels like every show
has it now but let's talk about your i
felt like every teen movie had boobs and
like
female full-frontal stuff and i had not
seen the opposite so that's why i wanted
to do that there's no female nudity in
the movie oh i meant like
shows that are on netflix now like sex
life or whatever that one was called oh
yeah like is it a prosthetic
everybody voting on the internet whether
i think it's a prosthetic or not i mean
that was definitely a prosthetic just
just to tell you i wouldn't have gotten
my actress that close to it um
so nor would i have ripped someone's
actual penis piercing
uh just just to calm all your brains
it's called the prince albert yeah
uh it is called the prince albert i
pierced it myself by the way
i pierced that prosthetic
because my interest was worth
to show it to everybody they they often
do like i feel like if you get that
you're like i gotta i guess i gotta show
people otherwise why did i do this right
right it has to be shown
um
that bit
is amazing
so if it's a prosthetic then
you don't get like a particular rate
didn't there used to be like ratings
issues if you had full frontal i think
it's still the same
rating it doesn't matter if it's a
prosthetic if it looks real i don't
think but it's it's an ar it's a hard r
as i like to say although it's not you
know it wasn't like released in theaters
so it's technically a tv you know it's a
hulu thing so we got we got away with it
i was very impressed by the way with
hulu letting me do that
i was like are you sure
okay
who's the pl who is the place to get
away with i guess i mean look what they
do on pin 15. do you watch penfold i do
i do they have like throbbing [ __ ]
yes but yeah yeah
yeah it's the network of
i was pierce dicks and throbbing [ __ ]
i'm sure they're proud of that
because we always have a lot of members
that are aspiring filmmakers can you
talk a little bit about having this be
your first fear experience
making a film like is there anything
that you sort of wish somebody would
have told you before you made a film
that you would
recommend
to other people like advice for
first-time filmmakers
i don't know that i wished anybody had
told there was no big surprises for me
where i was like oh no this is what
directing is like that didn't
really happen
um but if i was to give advice
uh to anybody directing anything whether
it's a feature or anything else it's
like
don't micromanage like hire
people that you really like and trust
and who are good at their jobs and if
they're good at their jobs they're going
to be better at their jobs than you are
that's what i did i hired people who
were much better at their jobs than i
could ever be
and then i
gave i told them what i wanted and we
worked together to to create something
but i always was like what do you think
what do you want to do what would excite
you
because
400 heads are better than one
and if we all have if i'm good at
communicating what my goal is and what
my vision is for it and and i am hiring
people who are also pumped about that
vision then the best thing is gonna
happen you know like it's gonna it's
gonna it's gonna be this collective
project that everybody is psyched to do
and it creates a better set environment
and it creates a better final product
because
there are so many people's um hands and
brains all over this movie that i could
have not done by myself i mean that's
why i'm against the like film by credit
because i
it's not a film by just me so many
people made this you know watching the
credits makes me tear up because i'm
like oh man so many people put like
their hearts and souls into this this is
the one
maybe not the one industry but one of
few industries where it's hard it's
really grueling and the hours are long
and the pay is usually not so great that
if you don't love it you don't do it you
have to love it to do it and that means
that for the most part everybody on a
set is doing their very best whether
that's good or not it might be shitty
but they are doing their very best so
that's something to respect and that's
something that is unique to this
industry that i really love so when you
hire people that you feel
um
good about and that and that it's
exciting then you have to trust them and
and then it becomes really fun all
around you know and then you don't feel
i don't feel as alone and like as scared
as a and as intimidated by the thing
because i have a team i have this like
ragtag team of people who are behind me
on this thing and then it's exciting you
know
i wanted to
that was a really good story thank you
uh
because i agree it's it's like what they
say about you never feel like you're
doing work if you were oh i didn't swear
you know i definitely felt like i was
doing work but it was it was fun work it
was good it definitely was painful yeah
it was it was work i was tired i was
very tired
a lot of work to do but it was fun
i was gonna say let's let's talk about
the
reproductive rights aspect of it
um
i don't necessarily want
i don't know what exactly that i want to
ask about it i mean you already talked a
little bit about
you weren't trying to hit it really hard
on the head
but still wanted to make
your point about it was there anything
in it that you changed like was the
planned parenthood originally open but
you decided to make it not open or
no
um
[Music]
no the planned parenthood was always
going to be closed
i you know the thing that just came to
my mind
uh
that has so much to do about like
it
it has to do
less with like um
um women's rights and and and health
care rights and more
more to do with um the way women and
girls are perceived and judged and um
and depicted in film and it's something
i learned on this movie and it
eventually has to do with these
healthcare rates which is that
um
in the sex scene with sonny and kyle
it was scripted that you know they're
both like she's very drunk kyle's
completely sober but uh on his margarita
mix but uh
but he thinks he's drunk
uh sunny is is totally drunk and it was
scripted that you know she uh they're in
this hug and she um
her eyes open and she's sort of like
makes a decision to reach down and like
you know touch his crotch right
and i shot it that way and my editor
who's fantastic um
uh
assembled it that way and the second i
saw it
you know it was like a
sort of a close-up shot of her opening
her eyes and then her hand going down
and then a reaction shot of him right
the second i saw that i was like oh we
can't do that and he was like why and i
was like because then you're the
audience is going to blame her the
entire time because they saw her make
the decision they're not going gonna
they're gonna be like
oh uh
this is her fault
she's dumb she should have made this
choice right and and i know that not
maybe not everybody would have blamed
her my editor certainly was like but why
girls can make mistakes too they should
be allowed to i don't understand and i
was like you don't understand girls and
women are judged so differently than
lead male protagonists and we have to
show this
this particular moment she still makes a
decision you still watch her do it but
if you watch it from the wide if you
watch it further back then it feels like
something that just happened
and not like you're watching her make
this decision that she's you're going to
spend 90 minutes watching her regret you
know
and
that's not something that necessarily i
would have done had been a male
character i don't know
but i it did make me realize a lot about
how women and girls are judged and how
like
you don't have a lot of female
anti-heroes and you know like it's very
hard for women to be anything but like
good mothers in something you know and
like and it and and that was a real
lesson for me um and for my editor we
had we had this really long amazing
discussion about it where we really
discussed it because
i just knew i just knew that i had to
shoot it another way i knew that it
would that that the people that i needed
to watch this people whose hearts i
needed to change and affect would not
keep watching if i didn't do it like
that um so i don't know that's okay
interesting it sounds like um
editing in that sense can be a very
instinctual process like you have to pay
attention to what your gut says yeah
what it makes you feel
you know you have to sort of separate
yourself from the creator and and watch
it as a viewer right and go what does
this make me feel does this make me and
put yourself in the position of a viewer
who's not you also like do i
so many times i think you know directors
or creators are like here's my thing and
you're did you get that i was trying to
tell you this and you're like no
sometimes sometimes you have to dumb it
down a little more than you would think
and sometimes you've dumbed it down way
too much you know what i mean so you
have to put yourself in the position of
of other people and of yourself as a
viewer to watch it but yeah it's it's
the editing process was really
fascinating for me on this i learned so
much about about just the perception of
girls and women and how we shoot things
and
and how how long to push the funny and
when to drop into the the dramatics it
was really it was really fun and
interesting to do
that's awesome yeah
uh yeah i get i kind of i'm sure
everybody else does too you get that
feeling when you're watching something
like it should have been cut before this
no it's too much no didn't need that in
there i didn't need that because it's
true when you're watching them in the
bathroom you know when she's touching
his junk right you look on both of those
you know it's her decision i didn't take
away her decision
i just manipulated you as the audience
member to not watch her eyes while she
makes it and then you don't blame her as
much which is so weird to say but you
don't
i could stay here on this stage with you
all night but i know they're going to
want to close the harmony gold at some
point so my last
two questions are
um
do you think uh
are you trying to line up another
directing project after this are you
trying to go more for acting projects um
i'm you know both i i i write and i act
and i direct and and so uh
i guess i would say all three is the
preferred thing um but not always
sometimes i like to not directing is
hard man directing takes a lot out of
your life i i i did not sleep for a lot
of nights because i was working all the
time and and it it really takes years to
do one thing and it also takes you away
from other things like
um
you know i i couldn't do acting jobs
while i was editing this so so it's a
real commitment and sometimes i just
want to act in something and like peace
out
which is nice to do uh but but yeah i i
i want to do it all and i want to keep
doing whatever i can get away with so
why not
last question is
if money's no object what's your dream
project
you know that's a good question um but
i'm not going to answer it because i'm
making it you're gonna make your dream
project i mean that's the goal why make
anything other than your dream project
is it sci-fi portrait of lady on fire
it's not i'll leave that to you don't
worry
you can have that i can't do it by
myself you can you can have friends you
can have help all right you do it thank
you so much for coming this is a lot of
fun thank you all for coming and staying
thank you so much
[Music]
you